good morning Millennials welcome back to
the morning toast
happy Monday I hope you're you know just
churn it out at work gonna watch the
toast then go meet Sally at the
watercooler debrief get lunch and then
the days over yeah and once Monday's
over when it's the summer the weeks over
it is officially the week of Jackson
Brittany's wedding and I still don't
have a dress so that's what I'll be
doing today again and I just I can't
stress enough how much shopping for
dresses makes me want to UM stab myself
no I I completely understand you have my
deepest sympathies and I think that
every time we shop or something it
really highlights like this big issue in
our society which is like where are the
clothes and you know what like you know
what the only thing that really helps
with like having to shop for dresses
which is just a miserable outing it's
when your sisters come with you and help
you that is how that is helpful that's
how they'll see yes just because I'm
going afterwards so like maybe I don't
know if you guys saw implants or
anything I don't know I just always have
a million things to do we'll see
whatever we've a big announcement
oh we do personal announcement that
we're really proud of that it's not
gonna affect anyone but just an update
in our business but we talked about it
on the patreon by the way we released
two patron episodes this week you really
[ __ ] premium episode she's really free
remember since yesterday's episode we
did it would you rather and like I guess
this was a Sunday really I feel as
though when we're doing podcast I'm
always like you know thinking about what
I'm saying but I just like was saying
yeah you were very relaxed I felt really
like unfiltered and some of the
questions submissions for would you
rather we got we're so disgusting that
I'm like really like scared of the
toasters now um but it was a great
episode and then we also did a part two
to our like instagrams bonk on episode
where we talked a lot about the
Instagram proposal manipulated around
the world right and it was really funny
because since Friday's episode like she
got married yeah and then also like
stopped posting yeah if she knew people
were over it and she never hit 200,000
she's she got to 199 and she's - what I
did I guess her friends didn't give her
my advice which was for her because
everyone is starting here but they're
not following clear so if you want the
Instagram engagement heard around the
world recap head over to the patreon
spank on part 2 has that recap and then
also you just get some more fun episodes
this month and you also get some
personal develop
one oh sorry I forgot is really really
I'm exciting about it but this is really
Claudius baby I came here not like that
excited I really am so excited but like
this is your meeting we got an office
toes HQ toast HQ it's gonna be so cute
it's small you know it's a starter
office it's a low budget but so are we
and it's really gonna need like a
creative eye cuz like the fluorescent
lighting is just like not it small as a
generous turn I can't I didn't think
it's this much job you like can't get
over it she's like think she's gonna be
like in a coffin it's a closet
it's an exciting closet it's a closet
and you know what it's really like
storage for like a part of part of what
we're paying is truly likes to get
things out of my house that like need to
sit at an office and to is just to like
I don't know the closets too small so
that's actually not Jackie's not have
cut up
no oh my god okay so rethink pivot
whatever I'm excited I mean I know I
said it's gonna be great for I think
company morale yep also company
productivity many a patron episode will
be recorded there and then also it might
turn into a sitcom because being in this
office was literally a second when we
were like touring spaces every person we
met like along the journey of the day
was just another character in a CBS
sitcom it was so funny because there are
so many shared work space it's like a
million think that we work is like the
only place to do it and you go there and
it's like oh it's a closet for literally
$9,000 a month and I'm like sorry No
so we were looking at other obvious
beats just like regular but it turns out
there's so many shared like we works but
you know for like less famous yeah less
famous and like less um millennial and
like less of a vibe you have more just
like corporate sells so we went to our
corporate cell and we just were meeting
so many people who like everyone was a
character who is trying to understand
what we do oh my god one guy asking for
my business card and I had one of my
hooker business cards bring it to print
you go toast and I gave it to him it was
so funny so like maybe we'll start our
grassroots reality show finally yeah I
just I'm really excited like I know you
think it's just a closet but like with
all the ideas that I have a literary
made a floor plan like a 3d one with all
the deer
it's gonna be the most beautiful class
we're gonna have a statement wall with
toasty banana leaf wallpaper the other
two walls are gonna be like a pastel
pink we're gonna cover the carpet was
just like a white carpet and we'll get
some different lighting she's just like
you know warm warm and what's more
lighting warm in a warm of five is there
a word for like make warm to warm up
warm in no there's no word book of
warming to warm up because it's a to
Worr adjectives to warm up I and it's an
adjective in you're trying to make it
into a verb okay so there's no word you
say I know like be whatever warmth I
whatever I'm gonna say dip your toes HQ
in the closet and I really don't think
it's that small and I want to go the
lazy boy but Jackie won't let me it's
too small sorry are we gonna get a TV
yes yeah for is to you know to watch
Reuters yeah for sure sees that we
actually the story from Reuters tonight
we do is exciting ya know he could have
watched Kardashian Theo cuz I didn't
watch you didn't know because we got
home so late I know when I still watch
your good sister just will recap for
tomorrow's episode which will be a
podcast on the episode so I'll watch you
say the rest of the week is podcast only
using our integrated interface I'm
really excited about it J heat oh wait
you were going with a warm yeah okay but
he's up to heat up warm up oh yeah I
guess yeah anyways we went to sacrum and
last night because our intern was just
like really wanting to go because our
intern demanded that we go so we took
her on a team off-site and it was really
fun they're so talented
I'm just like so tired because of it
like physically not I guess mentally I'm
just Monday vibes but physically like my
legs hurt from this concert it was a
jolly good show I didn't know a bunch of
songs and I don't like ride-or-die like
cream my pants
fours a crowd but I was I was thinking
like while I was listening to music I
didn't know like it was really an
enjoyable show in the sense that like
when I didn't know certain songs it was
still just like listening to talented
musicians play their fiddles get their
bases and just like rock out you know
yeah and compared to other shows that
I've been to more specifically like pop
shows when I don't
the song it's just like what is this
trash am i doing yeah I completely agree
the fiddler zach brown fiddler who's
definitely number two in command he's
the hardest-working fiddler in country
music and i think he's like the most
like if I were an aspiring violinist I
would be like I want to be like the
fiddler in background man like that
would be the goal like Yo Yo Ma or his
background skip Fiddler on the Roof yeah
or that girl Lindsey Stirling oh yeah
yeah she's a famous fiddler this guy is
like fiddling his way through honey's
like him the biggest ages in the world
like we chuckles he's our little E and
also singing at the same time which is
so impressed no but it's like the fiddle
itself is a voice of course no no the
fiddle is what the fiddle
okay the fiddle in the songs was acting
it's like the dubstep like beats and
other songs like after of course be like
dude and it's like a fiddle I agree I
was hanging or a few songs was like this
feels like EDM like right someone that I
used to know I'm and that's all violin
though that's what I just say yeah I
know is it pink song but Jackie was
singing cuz I'm like what songs do I
know Jackie when you were in the
bathroom drag was like beautiful drug
and I'm like can't get enough and I'm
like it's not pink I thought it was a
pink song no yes so but she's always
thinking about beautiful drugs yeah
country but they really cross genres in
any of their songs could be made into
like an EDM song they also have their
you know rock there oh yes they have
rock wait what are the song like toes
and knee deep that are more like what's
that word bluegrass okay yeah and not
poking but bluegrass yeah where it's
like you're just like on a raft with
your fiddle with your fiddle
yeah it was really a very great show a
jolly good show I'm tired but other than
that I think it was a good weekend yeah
it was a really nice weekend I'm truly
like I was thinking as her like I'm not
well still from GNO like and me and
Mario on Saturday night we it was Ben's
dad's birthday party and she was 60 and
birthday and we were trying to decide
like the birthday party ended at
midnight like should go out takes a nice
level it just I call it a night and go
home and I was really just like sitting
there trying to recapture the magic of
GNO and it wasn't happening and like
that's the problem with having such a
great night it's like it sets the
standard for every other night and every
other night is always
be a big letdown and not everybody be
great or else those nights wouldn't be
great yeah and if you didn't have those
great nights ever then you wouldn't even
try on the other night so it's like it's
aspirational also like it wouldn't have
been Aegean oh and there's something to
be said about the magic of a GN oh you
know like the boys would have come along
and then like you know some of us would
have been with husbands some without but
the GN oh it's like let's go did you
know that's it
you know it's such a simple concept yeah
it's a girl's revolutionary it's all
right
without you it is more than all right
and I'm really I'm gonna stay the [ __ ]
out and play the [ __ ] out without you
without you it's key so we'll do it
again soon don't worry
and I'm just like I'm still going to
down after I get my birthday will be
like one big pad you know yeah you know
watch you were bringing the hub's yeah
but like they'll be there too but like
they'll go to bed at like 11:00 cuz
their actual grandfather's yeah it's
like we all married 50-year olds I wish
but also we should plan our next you
know like around something how we wanted
to do like for Arianna we should get a
little ahead of Janna okay fine much
like when we get our office I think
that'll help us in terms like Peak Tram
planning schedule a scheduling no matter
Gianna I was thinking maybe we turn one
of the empty walls into like a full
calendar like I bet they make like
wall-sized calendars we can just rip it
off every month but how are we supposed
to reach a stepladder yeah we'll have
like snitch on the ladder like in hidden
figure so yeah kind of figure yes
solution I need your handwriting it's
not a good idea yeah you as the planner
and me is down with that it might start
to get a little Unga patched but um well
we could definitely we should have a big
planner like no Greg the toast calendar
and then we should take pictures of it
and put it on the Instagram so people
know when we're anywhere out yeah and
then also like when we're getting our
period oh yeah I just finished mine do
you think it's done
oh yeah I was like do we have Lola
coming today no no no okay I do think
it's time though tell you what the fast
five stories that you need to know
before you wake up and take a bite out
of your morning toast but before you
allow me to let you know that the fact I
store is that you need to know before
you make up an take about that every
morning toast it's brought to you might
open fit what is open fit open fit takes
all the complexity out of losing weight
and getting fit it's a brand new super
simple streaming service that allows you
to work out from the comfort of your
living room for as little as 10 minutes
a day everyone's bodies are different an
open fit gets at which is why it is
personalized
your needs with custom-tailored original
content open fit classes are led by some
of the most effective and engaging
trainers in the world sculpt your body
with engineer Rogers who is the founder
of worldwide sensation extend bar or
getting crazy good shape with Hunter
McIntyre named my Sports Illustrated
that's one of the top 50 fittest
athletes Wow they have not given me that
title open if it has changed the way we
work out we work out and without rocoto
so you can join us on our fitness
journey personalized just for you again
use our code toast and start using open
fit for your journey to a healthier life
right now during the open fit 30-day
challenge our listeners will get a
special extended 30-day free trial
membership to open fit where you can
lose up to 15 pounds in 30 days when you
text toast to 30 30 30 you'll get full
access to open fit all the workouts and
nutritional information totally free
again text toast
to 30 30 I need to lose 30 pounds in 15
days okay but I don't you know I'm not
about look setting unrealistic goals no
open yet or done that show you there
that should be their slogan gaiter done
we're just over here like rebranding all
the sponsors of the show you're welcome
anyways without further ado the story
today I think are quite diverse and
maybe I'm just missing some like major
slab news but maybe I don't care
first up though Karlie Kloss and josh
Kushner who I would say they said a
celebration and I think happened this
weekend except for that okay great
so we're right on track Carla cloths and
Josh Christian are tied the knot for a
second time over the weekend the couple
celebrated their nuptials at the Brush
Creek Ranch in Wyoming where a list
attendees such as Orlando Bloom Katy
Perry Derek Blasberg and garage magazine
founder Dasha Zhukova partied the night
away eight months after class and
Kushner married for the first time
Plattsburgh shared three photos of Kloss
and Kushner from the weekend giving a
snapshot of the couple in their Best
Western where before the ceremony and a
close look at crosses off-the-shoulder
white dress while Sheen Kushner were
lifted into chairs during the
traditional hora dance hava nagila very
cute okay I just have like so many
thoughts because like where was Taylor
Swift and the fact that Katy Perry was
there like I'm truly sick about I mean
even realized they were super close for
as I know that their mutual best friend
is Derek Blasberg but like how are they
so close and then I was watching Derek
Blasberg stories today and they were
taking a video I guess they were like oh
Horus I cried at Orlando jumped off his
horse like go pee in the woods and as
he'll just take his dick out any yeah no
way I said have no one no one as they're
panning even here Katy Perry singing you
need to calm down you're lying I started
kind of show you oh my god wheat and now
that Katie and Taylor are friends yeah
it's all good but it's like really where
was where was Taylor yeah like just I
love Tareq glasburgh for always getting
invited to all the most premium
celebrity events and being the only
person who takes pictures no and he
pulls premium content with premium
captions yeah I have it I mean Oh wasn't
it it wasn't hers
whose story was it that he said it was
Darren it was totally Derrick was
circled on well it's been more than 24
hours
oh my god I'm like what is that sound
it's my voice re-render class I thought
was good story wait no it's really
important because she sings one line
okay okay there he is peeing she's
singing home on the range Rhea
she was singing me one of these things
is not like the other like on that sign
no she might have not been singing me
Jerry because Jackie she is singing
along to the tune and that's like a a
well-known saying no I'm pretty sure she
was singing in my girl do you think I
don't know what it what she like changed
it tune but maybe she was just changed
she was heating the country well kid she
had a toothpick in her mouth yeah we'll
see whatever that honestly like if I was
a rich billionaire and I married another
rich billionaire like I would have a
country themed wedding on like the most
rich fancy reg in the world a hundred
percent but like where was everyone else
yeah so I heard that Miranda Kerr was
also there or going to Blues ex-wife and
that him and Katy were getting along
what's that wasn't at the wedding that
was at Miranda Kerr's Beauty launch
what's the connection between Miranda
Kerr she married you know how are they
friends know Carla it was somewhere else
that okay okay sorry I didn't click the
article I just assumed that's the only
place can you there's a premium and I
really appreciated that they weren't
like storing all weekend like throwing
it in our faces because they obviously
were like don't tell anyone that we're
here but then once it's over you can
post cuz everyone was posting last
minute like I saw scooter bronze-y
posted 72 and I just appreciated that
cuz I hate feeling FOMO like of things I
would never be invited to you know like
I'm really having the most incredible
crippling fear of missing out from Joe
and Sophie's wedding in France like I'm
dying like I can't believe I'm not there
and like like we're friends like I swear
sure but okay say you were invited in
your perfect world but then what about
Jax and Brittany who are you closer with
oh my god
in know like no I think Jackson Bertie
might understand like I wouldn't 1000%
go to Joe and Sophie's wedding and I I'm
just like I'm so upset like I can't
watch the story it's like I was watching
Joe's story today like on a boat with
Wilmer Valderrama and like I wanted to
die like I have such crippling anxiety
about like not being there even though
like why would I be there I don't know I
just like really want to would you
rather be at that wedding or the Vegas
wedding the France one yeah but it also
seems too short best friends only this
is like a week-long thing so I'm like
they're getting married on the weekend I
guess also so I guess the Jonas the
brothers Jonas took Willmar side against
Demi
mmm-hmm but Wilmer and Jamie are on
really good terms but like but like will
Jamie be at the wedding
definitely not she wasn't at Vicki
Briana's and they weren't somewhere for
her recently and she wasn't in the
documentary that's what but oh that's
true but the breakup has busy like
Olivia Copa the breakup has been between
Nick and Demi
they're the ones who had the fight so
him her not being at his wedding makes
sense but Honjo are technically on good
terms but they were also the ones who
were the closest Nick and Demi Nikki
yeah and Joe is her ex technically yeah
like sort shit'll school she was written
out of history Oh Olivia culpo who we
have some tea about according yeah no
sir Santi could not see this in the
group oh yes she was at the airport with
my [ __ ] everywhere she was in the
airport with a man named Christian
Messiah named McAfee's for the Panthers
yes commander please please oh my god
horrific he gets paid by the Panthers
he's a running back people apparently
know him I think he's good in his craft
anyone know him very very good Oh also
his teammate Cam Newton is he on the
same team right how did you see the
video of him offspring a guy on a plane
$1500 for his extra leg room scene and
the guy turned it down Wow
it was a 10-hour flight I don't know why
he wasn't in first class but are you
kidding the guy literally turned it down
and there's videos everywhere it's like
so embarrassing that's actually not
embarrassing that's relatable and I
think anyone I mean not me
I think I'm the exception but anyone
like has money would do that because
that's like yeah you think you're better
because and you'll sit with each other
saying how much would you how much it's
enough to pay you give up your seat I
guess it's not a 10-hour flight to sit
like in the shitty seat till we get you
$1500 yeah we do it I was really sad for
Cam Newton that he's not even in like
Delta comfort yeah that's what I'm
saying he was looking for Delta comfort
someone probably sucked up like he's
probably has to be in first class or
comfor and then by the time we got to
the airport there was nothing left his
PA definitely [ __ ] up because he
doesn't have a smitten yeah exactly I
would never let that happen
Taipa yeah it was an administrative
error for sure yeah anyways so it looks
like Olivia culpo is a new man it's
definitely on the DL but now the
toasters no because it's in the
and I'm happy for her know that I am
know that I am I just
I do wish like she would stay out of
dating athletes like a court Khloe
Kardashian situation like it hasn't
worked out maybe like what you're
looking for you really can't be found in
an athlete like what about a businessmen
beau I know I know and like if it's
gonna be an athlete like maybe one in a
in a state where you have a home yeah
Matt Harvey
except for Carolina are apparently
really nice so like maybe he's just
trying to move it Danny was in Miami
like no then she bought an apartment
like maybe she's moving to the Carolinas
she loves country music like that's just
but I do think I'm really still holding
out hope for her and Matt Harvey like
New York is her home no sir he's not her
home she has a home in New York no she
rented an apartment while she was
filming model squad okay I just really
like like her about her I go I don't
think he's like enough for her oh my god
really I do also who's better at
football Christian or Danny Amendola
Christian is better at football quote by
far
Ben Danny I'm pretty sure Danny Amendola
sucks now I've gotten Megan but my
century back to the irony of it all
because baseball players make way more
money and I just think like I really
want her to be with a baseball player if
she's gonna go athlete football players
like I feel like the environment is
really salacious okay I agree these
things there's a lot more stability look
Nick Swisher and Joanna Garcia like
they're like such a real-life couple a
rod and JLo I just feel like you get a
good husband out of a baseball player
Kate Upton and Justin Verlander
thank you I don't know I just that's
what I'm feeling I okay I agree baseball
sure but I don't agree on that Harvey
there has to be like one other player Oh
what about like Mike Piazza I don't know
who that is but I they do I think he's
playing for the Mets which is a Guy in
10 days came on years ago oh my god
that's so funny
no Noah syndergaard we're a hockey guy
you're like what about wing ski they
don't have teeth your mere yogurt what
about 16 who just won the Bruins oh okay
no I really think baseball like is her
thing
something so prestigious about baseball
especially like dating if someone
Americas but also why just the Yankees
or Mets the Boston Red Sox that's where
she's trapped I don't know anyone who
plays I know that shot they always win
yeah that's true Nate you always wonder
and Hannah
Jeter oh yeah they made such he made
such a wife out of her she made such a
man out of him I'm telling you there's
something like underrated in baseball
players okay and then who's the one
there's two Mets ordinate Yankee to New
York players right now who are like Oh
judge Tamra son Tamra judge he's too
young for Olivia culpo she needs like an
established man who's like about to
retire so they can like have a family
I'm telling you but he's not about to
retire but like Noah syndergaard yeah
he's like it's too like in the mix maybe
it's too like socialite like my Matt
Harvey was on the cover of the New York
Post because he went out to one oak till
6:00 in the morning and then couldn't
play he sounds like you on Friday you
showed up yeah taxi like he may have
showed up but he couldn't play but like
I think no worse in neurons like going
through that phase right now
whereas like he'll come out like now
Matt Harvey is like an established
person like player and he wills you know
like I just have a feeling yeah I don't
know I'm goning for Mike Piazza me doing
I actually like Mike Piazza has like uh
like a wife and likes grandchildren he
thinks so and like they live in Queens I
think so too
anyways Jim Edmonds great guy we were
going into our second story we're gonna
use our second story but it does seem
like Olivia culpo is in a new
relationship so enews I know you're
watching like if you want to get the
scoop just go to the toaster screw yeah
if you could just like like plug my
Instagram that be yes I want Instagram
right or just anything yeah SEOs
Instagram we'll take it next up inside
Kylie Jenner and Kendall Jenner 70s
themed night out with Sophia Ricci but I
saw I just you know this end okay theme
night out but Kylie kendall and Sophia I
have been hanging out they have their
Handmaid's Tale party that was just like
criticized around the world
yeah and I'm so here for this they were
best friends back in the day I know I'm
totally here for it I just want to know
how Courtney's reaction to it cuz I
think this might only get money with
Kourtney and Kendall's like weird
friendship oh for sure which we'll talk
about because in my mind like Kourtney
is in love with Scott and like seeing
have such a stable normal relationship
with a young girl who like arguably is
like younger hotter than Courtney like
he's driving her crazy and she wants him
back but he won't have her back because
he's so happy that's like what I think
is going on in my mind I don't think
that she's in love with him but I do
think it does like make her mad to see
him like be the person that he used
meant to be but with someone else like
right you know and she's just like yeah
you know uh but I do think that yeah if
he had been like half as loyal of like a
husband and father to Courtney as he is
- Sofia like they would still be
together yeah and it's just it's
annoying that Courtney put in all this
work to make him a better person only
first Sofia to enjoy the benefits of
like the new better healthier Scot but I
don't think that Courtney made him a
better person me neither but like all
the time yeah I agree with that but
maybe and it doesn't seem like a good
luck charm say to a ssin where she just
had him ready for the night no because I
don't see Eunice out here like you know
met wiping up anyone exactly exactly um
so they're all hanging out now which I
guess probably started because Courtney
and Sofia were hanging out too like they
all got her glass thing but I don't
think Courtney expected for them to all
be become best friends and that know
that that has to hurt and now they're
like hanging out without her and like
having like themed parties and it must
hurt Courtney so much was like Courtney
feels like she's going through this
phase where she wants to hang out with
teenagers because like she's hanging out
with all Kendall's friends and now she
really can't because it's just like a
conflict of interest so she must be
feeling even extra hurt like that she
actually physically can't go or maybe
like Courtney ruined Kendall's other
friendships so like Kendall made new
friends when she drove Kendall to this
place and that Courtney can't actually
ruin because she can't get in here right
but I'm really happy for the gals and
I'm really happy for Kylie because I was
watching last night's episode which I
guess I won't spoil it too much for you
ever to watch it today but it's like
Jordan she put all of her eggs in
Jordan's basket like Jordan was the
friend of all friends and once that went
down like it's clear that she's
investing more in other friendships now
like sobs that whole trip for stassi's
birthday where did they go I must know I
need that Jenelle suit can someone find
it on Alibaba for me they were in Palm
Springs so they were yeah Oh amazing
anyway so she's investing more in other
Fred Chris's house and now she needs to
like invest in people who are already in
the circle and I think her turning to
Sofia is a genius
Sophia wouldn't turn on them because
she's in it she's a part of the family
she's a part of the family so I I just
want like the best for Kylie and her
friendships like could you imagine if we
got like a Sophia collab at Kylie
cosmetics oh my god I would die like
Kylie and so if you have the same
stylist who does premium what was it Joe
Jacobs okay so like Courtney has I just
started following Kourtney stylist who
like I hate Kourtney but she has been
looking really good and she also does
Erica Jane Danny Michelle okay it's just
come out she's so pretty okay um so it's
like Kourtney really has been like
amping it up lately and it's due to her
new stylist who else's child Stassi for
the VMAs that's right and Movie Awards
with the white fur thing that's a good
chef yeah right what if entities many
awards yes
cute they always get great stylist
except for there was a minute there
where it wasn't working for after Monica
Robles there was a slump but yeah
Kendall is style Mimi fright I only know
Kylie silence okay popcorn at the Zac
Brown Band concert and litter I sell the
kernel of ideas that's the literal story
of my life that's Natalie the cross to
bear when you were eating popcorn that
will be like the title of my book yeah
like I need the pointiest tongue ever
because I'm constantly picking [ __ ] out
of my teeth you need a tongue that's a
finger like we do them are would you
rather is episode yesterday it sounds
like a premium experience yeah you said
you would take that tongue finger and
scratch your back your throat I would
pick our Colonel sir my throat is itchy
right now and it's started itching when
I had a sip of this coffee made for me
better the PPA omaeda PA is poisoning us
I do I really really do I'm coming for
your jobs
what Oh both of ours now Jesus waters I
see my it's just water
she just needs one of us to go down yeah
and I guess like you are the one being
more strict about the office and maybe
she just wants you to go down so she can
put a lazy boy in the corner I don't
know that's you Wow maybe it's a it's a
tag team just like the snapping up there
in the ceiling I'm the cop are you
oh yes perhaps okay let's move on um
okay so that's just a cute fact way that
they're all hanging and they went to a
70s theme party and they all looked
super Indy like are getting dressed up
together and I'm loving it and I have to
imagine
this is causing strife between the
Corson Courtney and that that makes me
happy I know but what doesn't make me
happy is knowing that like the family
could be striped with because if that
was the case like Kylie was so on the
right side of history on last night's
episode like you didn't even bat an
eyelash she was just like you're done um
she just understood completely she was
like hey she also was like if I ever
decide to like have a relationship with
Jordan like she also wasn't being like
so militaristic right but she knew in
the moment so I guess I wouldn't like to
think that someone could easily come
between the sisters even if it is
Kourtney just wouldn't bode well for the
rest of the family yeah but Sophia is
technically family now do you think Mary
because Scott always wanted to marry
Courtney Scott yes Scott is definitely a
marriage type of guy I just don't know
if Sophia could do it
because of the Lionel of it all Lionel
has expressed many times that he doesn't
approve and after watching American Idol
I really love Lionel and I feel like
he's a good dad but I feel is that when
Lionel said he didn't approve
none of us approved we were all
unbelievably grossed out by this
relationship now we're all on board I
have to think Lionel has come around
like Scott now has a brand he's a family
man like Sophia I imagine she seems
happy like I think he has to come around
what she's still not talking to her dad
like I don't know what doesn't Cole what
you think of this I need to know I think
she's here for him me too I I really do
she's like so normal I am makes you
think makes you think next time a little
sports me is Sansa's sports heavy show
rams coach Sean McVeigh engaged to his
girlfriend Veronica coming talking about
those Sean McVeigh Rams co2 it's a Super
Bowl oh yes oh I actually know he was
youngest head coach in football QT I
know her she's woman who's beautiful and
they're just like up and coming and it
seems like an interesting factoid okay
that is not what's the team the Rams the
LA Rams they were in the Super Bowl oh
yeah everyone loves Sean McMann coming
back it's all coming back to me now it
would be like if Bill Belichick was
engaged yeah except except that I know
who Bill Belichick is yeah not married
no he is he's married okay - Lynda
holiday you make some muffin commerce
it's not like news we needed to know
okay you woke up in a really dry day
no I like this was like an early penny
where they get the Aged on Saturday
Veronica the model girlfriend of Rams
head coach revealed the two gotten
engaged while vacationing in France
anything to do with Fran's win now who
did the picture is the kardashians the
kardashians quote can't wait to calm my
husband she got on social media Veronica
who has been linked to McVeigh since
2011 famously rocked a McBay t-shirt
which featured her husband's mug during
the Greek Rams Saints showdown earlier
that's really cute yes so like she's a
cutie they're cuties and these seem like
people that we're gonna be seeing more
well is this an episode of the Schmidt's
literally maybe this is cross so if you
don't know is our new show that we
launched under the toast News Network
hosted by Ben boys no John my husband
and it's too high school gal pals
what do you call gal pals fire boy guy
pals guy friends friends Bros Rose
brother drugs homie brother dog that's
what they call his friends it's called
the Schmidt's SH BITC there's a Facebook
group called the Spitzer's it's for all
things sports so if you're a sports gal
or your husband likes sports or you know
someone who likes sports
feel free to recommend it to them new
episode I think is coming out tomorrow
also tis the season really for people to
get engaged like Facebook is poppin
these days with engagements and
Instagram like I think May June are
really engagement having months because
people like that engage for like a year
and then May June is like wedding season
for actual weddings so it's a nice time
of year to propose because I saw birdies
get that bug too and coaches you know
and influencers who make their own pitch
X oh for sure yeah well I'm happy for
these two she got it out of the right
time you know it's a new fresh team
young guy mm-hmm he could be the next
wheel belcheck he could be or the next
Rex Ryan or the next Coach Taylor uh
ain't it good to be the couch ain't it
good to be the cat okay next story biz
news from Reuters the big Reuters story
el dorado resorts clinches 18 billion
dollars cash and stock for Caesars so El
Dorado resorts is merging with Caesars
Entertainment Corp what does El Dorado
um look what does an El Dorado property
have I ever stayed at one um probably
we're good
one second we'll get into it when I find
the answer this our company which emerge
from bankruptcy operates casinos with
Harrah's and horse shoe brands oh you
know I'm Paris yeah oh this is a huge
merger and this is a huge merger well
what does it need for our trip to Vegas
I don't know huh makes you think maybe
if we tell this story right it'll change
things
Caesars us casino operator El Dorado
resorts which I love and couldn't wait
to chat has agreed to merge with Caesars
Entertainment Corp which I also love in
a cash and stock deal that values its
pier at about 18 billion dollars
including debt people familiar with the
matter said on Sunday the agreement
comes three months after reuters
reported that Caesars had agreed to give
Eldorado access to its books under
pressure from billionaire investor Carl
Icahn who earlier this year was awarded
seats on caesar's board hmm maybe we
should all just stab Caesar literally
the deal which is expected to be
announced monday on the morning toast
values Caesars that close to 13 dollars
a share according to the sources the
combined company's ownership would be
split roughly between El Dorado and
Caesars shareholders the sources said
this article it's like really difficult
for me because like for Sultan Reuters
and the word Reuters like Reuters really
bothers me and we're talking about
Caesars scissors like I think words that
are spelled like that Kings ears you
mean chasers yeah caiis errs I totally
orders the combination of the two
companies would create a serious
competitor to larger casino industry
players such as Las Vegas Sands Corp
Wynn Resorts lid yeah Limited and MGM
Resorts International so now we have
another heavy hitter on the scene and
this just seems like another you know
big monopoly that's happening and you
know if they're also competitive maybe
one can like you know really stand out
from the others by sponsoring my
birthday party July 11th or 14th in
Vegas yeah I think that that would just
really like pivot them the needle yeah
me too and really have a clear
number-one you guys can buy your stocks
and like we can all live happily ever
after soundly yeah just something to
think about
anyways I do you think this is quite
interesting meet you I mean Harris is
like such a low-level chain that they
think I think they really could use a
facelift from a billion dollar company a
billion dollar buyout and from Caesars
which like has prominence from The
Hangover it's the real Caesars Palace
and it's made out of real marbles yeah
it's really expensive it's impressive
when you think about the archeological
feat of Caesars Palace it's really it's
astounding
it's a sounding so I'm happy for you
know the whole Caesars
it seemed like you know they were bought
out of some debt it seems it's the word
Caesar explained to me how it's a person
in a salad and also a wrap
that's why is this Caesar salad called a
Caesar salad maybe because there's
something Roman about it Roman romaine
lettuce hmm interesting
I'm sure there would be an easy surge
but also a chance that they're not
linked whatsoever right then it would
just be weird yeah they should totally
just tell Caesar
cream with a fork Caesar dressing was I
started and you know this limit Irish
region region of California just
something to think about
yeah or something to Google which she
still seems to not be doing I'm googling
it okay let us know it's named after the
man who invented it whose name just also
happened to be Caesar Cardini
yeah Caesar Cardini then it's just like
I invented the salad right like he won
in Mexico Cesar Millan Cesar Millan and
his very controversial mode of training
dogs he's falling under a lot of
scrutiny if you had a dog and Susan
Millan wanted to train it would you let
him if someone wanted to check I have a
dog yeah I would take any training no
Susan Millan is a really controversial
okay good I'd have to look into it
better I'm not gonna go off with like
your word that he's controversial but
it's true I would look into it I met him
once
are you ready trophy final story
insurance you don't seem ready you know
what I'm not okay
I'm hungry honestly I'm sorry I need to
go home and whip up a meal do it maybe
one from great chef please which green
chef by the way is a hello fresh company
and I love green chef because they're
very similar yeah but they have
additional options and I can get
pescetarian oh yeah so hello fresh
launched green chef which lets you
choose from a wide array of
easy-to-follow
life styles with select organic
ingredients recipes are quick and easy
with step by step instructions chef tips
and photos to guide you along
everything is hand-picked and delivered
right to your door ingredients come pre
measured perfectly portioned and mostly
prepped
green chefs expert chefs design
flavorful recipes for your lifestyle
that go way beyond ordinary
substitutions diverse array of meal
plans with plenty of options to choose
from each week so you can actually enjoy
sticking to your goal
enjoy clean ingredients you can trust
seasonally sourced for peak freshness
now if you go to green chef dot us slash
toast 75 you can get a total of $75 off
that's $25 off each of your first three
boxes at green chef GRE and sha F dot u
s slash toast 75 love it yes yeah they
really they have every single dietary
need on there and it makes it super easy
yeah so turn your pescetarian lifestyle
I might just be a green chef
Oh didn't - right now you seem ready you
didn't oh yeah no I'm totally ready now
I made that money and I'm ready Paris
may be offering flying taxis to 2024
Olympic guests you can be sure that
transportation will be a nightmare for
many people attending the 2024 Paris
Olympics in five years but technology
can make it slightly more bearable
Arab or Airbus airports de Paris and
Paris Transport Authority are exploring
the feasibility of using autonomous
flying taxis to carry visitors from
Charles de Gaulle Airport into the city
when it takes roughly an hour to get to
Paris using a bus or train this could
save valuable time that would be better
spent finding a hotel and you know
enjoying the Olympics you wouldn't have
to wait long either as taxis could take
off every six minutes
they're already flying masa nations
underway airports de Paris has to pick a
site for a flying taxi hub in Paris by
the end of 2019 and it should be ready
within the 18 months the team will test
the link through an existing helicopter
corridor according to ATP's Edward
Arkwright I love reading random people
sayings on this show and like seeing
yeah there are many pieces that have to
fajn place for this to work the taxis
themselves have to be both safe enough
to fly and last long enough like battery
the partners also have to ensure that
the taxis mesh well with existing
infrastructure and regulations so it is
all about the infrastructure yeah no I
mean is it just a plane that like lands
closer
first of all and then you get in another
plane just like they're calling them
taxis I know but what is it I don't know
if they're like a lethal plane and how
many people can it they said like is it
communal it's like an uber pool or is it
like everyone gets their own taxi like a
real cab I does that seems
a really waste of infrastructure I agree
and I have to imagine they're like
little planes that are just taking them
into the city but I don't think they
would be calling them taxis then they
would say like shuttles plane shuttles
right if it's like two people look like
I'm a boomerang and my taxi is coming
and it's flying to me that's in a car in
the air or is it a plane I don't know to
the wheels like go up and down I don't
know I don't know that's interesting is
it helicopters no because then they
would say that they said they would use
a helicopter matches first of all I
didn't even know that the Olympics were
gonna be in Paris me neither so that's
like the first bit of the story I wonder
if they're gonna have the fashion and
Bastion s sing the national anthem since
she is now the face of Paris I don't
know I heard they're looking into it but
like she's so busy or god Bless America
some show like that yeah no it's France
oh wait what is the is it indoor outdoor
summer winter
okay I'm one of the activities like
swimming swimming gymnastics volleyball
because we know lenita I'm pretty sure
it's summer dude yeah we just had a
winter and then we're coming up on
another summer actually underrated
Summer Olympic sport is beach volleyball
Kerri walsh-jennings member her yeah she
was amazing like I just loved her and
her partner I think she retired though
also we get basketball which is always
fun yes the Americas sweep sweep except
- no Gallinari does play for Italy
that's really giving America a run for
their money that's really upsetting no
there's so many people who play in the
NBA like Dirk Nowitzki hits a play for
Germany or wherever it's on but like
there's not so many people I got it I
was like we're hockey like we lose all
of our players to Russia
yeah and Russia but for past looks like
the one sport we have yeah but no but
there it's really funny about like the
few that have to go home yeah or even
like the Toronto Raptors
oh my god totally know they're from
America so they could still play but if
there's people from Toronto playing the
Toronto Raptors yeah that is so
interesting to think about because now
we're internationally make remember when
Lamar Odom went to the Olympics of
course
Lamar Odom like really crash and burn
cuz he was on such a high when he met
khloe's six-man at the air really sad
do you think that Khloe and Lamar are
gonna end up together because know why
he's finally
man she needed hardly single she didn't
even try to go back to him like after
everything she thought it was like meant
to be and like she got in my house like
they were gonna work on it but like it
wasn't like doing drugs but I don't
think he's doing that anymore I don't I
just I don't think that's it like after
all of this if she ends up with Lamar
like I'll be disappointed on the site
but they were like so perfect for each
other they were perfect for each other
when like he was six Man of the Year and
go to the Olympics like yeah now that he
like really liked but now he's in New
York Times bestseller okay I don't think
that's like even comparable to LA Laker
bunny no I think I'm not worried about
money
she works hard you know but don't you
want like someone who's just as
ambitious as you um sort of but like
their ambition then like also it makes
them super ambitious about cheating on
her so their ambition makes it
impossible for them to ever hang out
schedule-wise Taylor Kinney Lady gaga
right justice du/dt Lady Gaga one two
and then why you event where brother it
was like Bradley Cooper's about at the
Kimmel Center but not as a brand I
graduate about Bradley Cooper goes
halfway why wouldn't you graduate you
know I mean he did an event at like
Kimmel like some filmmaker thing and she
came with him interesting interest not
but just went him wait you so that's
true
bringing in a woman yeah maybe it'd be
like a viewers thing a cool date like of
course I would go right but we're
related they're not okay so like it
would be a former coworker actually
never mind weird um
what was I just gonna say about Lamar I
forget I don't think it's it you know
yeah editor in French Montana
Michu I'm French is still in the group
yes because he's doing Scots show she
does read uh Scott
French's theatre but they go out with
French all the time he seems like a good
guy who like they brought around Anna
didn't work out and there was no like
contention and there was no like bad
blood but they really vibed with him and
he was someone they could trust like
when they find someone they could trust
they don't let go Jonathan Cheban
know so it just makes me feel as though
why is definitely a wasted like penis
yeah someone needs to date him yeah
Chloe Chloe I really like them together
I can't believe you didn't watch the
episode because I I'm gonna watch it
today and then we'll let me know so the
episode really centers around the day's
like two days before and two days after
it all happened um and it's it's really
just while - I'm not sure
in it at all in the beginning right
before it all goes down and they
definitely spliced scenes together like
Chloe is moving so she's walking Jordon
Kendall and Kylie around her house
showing the renovations that she's gonna
do and Jordan is like oh my god I'm
gonna come to your gym like just it's
crazy
actually it must have not been that far
away because Chloe then moves into a
rental so she can have her home
renovated and that night tonight only
shine out your husband's cheating on you
with your sister's best friend but also
to be in a rental like she was having
horrible migraines like although she had
to get an MRI they were so bad oh my god
but everything was okay okay spoiler
alert
um and so next week it seems as though
that's when red Table Talk airs she's
screaming at the phone liar it has to be
about that interview in which she
definitely lie because she also lied to
Chloe like in the hours after oh you
just wait yeah and don't watch them
either no I'm at midnight yeah I will
today and then tomorrow's episode which
it's gonna be a podcast only episode we
will recap it in depth okay maybe we'll
do the entire episode as a Kardashian
interview and I just well we do you know
what we did an entire episode as Jordan
woods I'm red Table Talk review right
and we deserved like to give that same
respect to Chloe especially because I
don't know if I've said this like
recently I'm so team Chloe on this do I
know we are in the world turned off well
we felt bad for Jordan just because she
was getting like the brunt of just
internet culture which just no one who
makes it really spiking stupid mistake
like deserves to have but she made it
really [ __ ] stupid mistaken like I
there's no one side to be another and
it's one thing to make a mistake but how
do you react after that mistake is
almost just as important and it seems as
if she didn't do it properly and no one
Chloe was so calm like even in her text
to Jordan she was like I love you like
she was like I love you just wanted to
know the truth and like Jordan wasn't
giving that to her story kept changing
and like she was like dodging Chloe's
calls and like even when she woke up the
next morning Kylie was like she was
smiling like she didn't say anything
like a sociopath right so it was all
about her reaction but like Chloe's so
she's such a forgiving person like look
how much she has forgiven yes she would
have forgiven Jordan she just didn't
handle it right yeah so it's not about
it's another of the crime it's always
the
always that's what is so frustrating
spoiler alert about dead to me oh no no
no I just I'm on Episode like three now
just please please I'll finish it
probably by tonight okay guys we can't
talk about it yeah okay fine look at the
okay they did okay okay so Kardashian's
recap will come at you tomorrow every
episode this week is podcast because
Tuesday's me and you Wednesday's also
meaning you yes every week is me new oh
yeah maybe I'll do one with stench
maybe if I were integrated interfaces is
not problematic yeah and then Friday its
you in stench okay cuz summer goes back
and I'm staying in Kentucky and I also
need to go find a dress like just
everyone like take a minute and like
pray for me because I'm Joe Saxon um
actually you're only Minnesota right
yeah money to her mom America oh I just
don't want to leave my house without a
dress yeah I hear if I happen to find
something at the Mall of America like
great good for me but I just I can't
rely on that like I'm not a girl like
that who can just like buy something in
a store and just like wear it without
like needing 500 alterations and like a
space isn't gonna if we even have the
time no but like who is that girl like
when I asked um Debbie our wedding
planner I'm like what is the craziest
thing that's ever happened to you at a
wedding and she was like you know how to
hang the dress I'm like a rod for the
video and they like they hung it on a
pipe and the pipe leaks and the girl's
dress got completely ruined and Debbie
was like she was the chillest girl she
like literally ran like into town to
some random bridal store like bought a
dress she wasn't Jewish and she was like
super skinny yes I bought a dress in
Ward I'm like what like that I was just
that's crazy
whoo Wow yeah Wow too bad she didn't
have two dresses
makes you think um okay thanks for
listening guys I mean thanks for
watching today is our only video episode
so until Friday until Friday if you have
some extra time feel free to head over
to YouTube to like this video give it a
thumbs up because we go live Monday
through Friday 10:30 a.m. Eastern Time
on YouTube feel free to subscribe I'm
also available as a podcast for your
commuter you know you don't like to
watch how much more of listener head
over to the podcast app on iTunes or
Spotify or stitcher
subscribe follow leave a thumbs up five
star review about how beautiful skinny
we are yeah I'm not that much work you
have to do just to make the show go
around so thank you guys for me
you'll be a great time weight of your
time we will see you Friday
or are we have a dare to cheat
you